let's talk about salaries for reality
shows of course I'm behind the scenes
would I would tell you as you come into
reality television if you start as a
logger transcriber you started as a PA
you start at any entry-level position
you're probably looking at between
depending on the company 450 and 850 a
week they don't see a lot of 450s
anymore but it does still happen as you
move up into an assistant story producer
position or sometimes referred to as an
Associate Producer position you could be
looking at 8:52 possibly 1250 as a story
producer this is per week this is not an
hourly like $8.50 is's as you move into
a full story position you're looking at
maybe super low-end 900 950 up to about
1500 or 1800 as a story producer
sometimes as much as 2,000 but it's very
rare senior story positions 1800 to 2500
supervising producer positions again
probably 2,000 to 3,000 or a little bit
more get up to a supervising producer co
EP level 3000 to maybe 4,500 a week a
week
and when you're in ep it's pretty broad
I mean I've seen executive producers
depending on their level of
participation in the show making $10,000
a week or more it can happen most of the
time it's a little more grounded between
maybe 5 & 8
you